i've heard you talk about why slapping
someone
is so much more
it gets your point across so much more
than if you were to punch somebody
i'ma tell you to i'ma tell you to really
[ __ ] ever
when i was in prison
my man explained this to me and i told
the story before
he said yo cause you know i wasn't i was
locked up in time and we was you know a
lot of cuttings and we was cut we would
be cutting
cutting each other and [ __ ] like that
right
and
i was getting i was trying to go home
and i was trying to get away from some
of the [ __ ] i was involved in
so a friend of mine told me some [ __ ]
about
slapping
[ __ ]
he really explained this to me like it
was a art
he said yo man you could smack [ __ ] i
said yo when you smack a [ __ ] he gonna
take that dish back he gonna go crazy he
said nah
he said
when you smack a [ __ ] why you right
when you talking to him
the average [ __ ]
is going to go into shock
you gotta understand [ __ ] what all these
rappers is talking about
the average man is not
as valid as they acting like
i'm talking about
don't you ain't got time to go get your
gun and all this other [ __ ] i ain't
talking about that i'm talking about
being straight up violent
fighting cutting stabbing right here on
the spot everybody not with that all
right
so
if you smack a man the average person
the average man is going to go into like
a shot like oh my god like his mind is
is going to be frazzled he just told me
because
he felt like
the audacity of you to smack him
is so shocking at the same time
it's it's fearful because he's saying
damn this [ __ ]
smack the [ __ ] out me and
and that's what that's what chris rock
said told you same exact thing same
exactly he explained this to me many
years ago and the same thing that chris
rock displayed is what he was talking
about yes what he talked about and
it really works
i've shot it if will would have went on
stage and punched him totally different
reaction even if he would have took the
punch sometimes sometimes a punch is
different right
a smack is more audacious it's more
disrespectful it's a psych it's
psychological
chris said oh [ __ ]
wow
will smith just smacked the [ __ ] out of
me
and this is what he talked about and i
tried it tried it many times after that
and it works
i'm telling you it really works no not
now that's not to say that
that works for every man right
you go like this to some [ __ ]
and they wit it
you understand so it doesn't it doesn't
work with every man but what did i say
earlier the average man is not as
violent as you think he is
the average walking person is just not a
violent person right i don't think
everybody's is equipped or or or
everybody is in instinctively in violent
that way you understand so
it [ __ ] works